why is everybody telling me Ant-Man is
trash because people are [__]
hypebeast even when it means people got
hypebeast for the internet so everybody
if they'll go online look at what the
popular opinion is and run with it hey
man he's great I I thought he was I wish
you would have got killed though why why
because it would have showed how much of
a threat King really is uh I feel like
Kane went out a little too like a little
too soft for him to be the big bad
threat that we know he is you know what
I'm saying like I wish he would have
like killed that man or maybe the WASP
you could get rid of the wasp
did he kill anybody was there anybody
that no and he kept talking about all
the Avengers he killed but you didn't
kill any like yeah you got to show me
killing him yeah killing those kills
half the [__] world that's right I'm
seriously I love the first scene in The
Avengers when he takes out Loki yeah he
also set the tone he also beats the [__]
out of the hole that's what I'm saying
remember the guy said let him have his
fun so much so that the Hulk had [__]
erectile dysfunction for the rest of the
goddamn
yeah think about that but that was the
last one it was like it built up we saw
a lot of famous second to the last one
yeah
it was one of the best opening scenes to
an action movie ever take out a dude
yeah that thing was fire okay those won
bro oh yeah and they left us hanging for
a year yeah yeah he knows one bro